Oh my god, hello, hello everyone, I'm so tired already Oh my
god, I just had to You know, like those moments when your
when your mom comes into your room And then like talked to
you for like 30 minutes And I'm just like, I have a stream,
please Please mom, I have a stream, please Please She came
in, she's like, okay, we need to talk about business.
I was like, I have a stream, mom, please.
Let me...
No, I don't want to be zoned out before the stream.
I need to hike myself out.
Oh, my God.
Sorry.
So I'm like, I'm already like mentally exhausted at the
moment.
I'm like, I'm already like mentally And I'm like, and then
she left like two minutes before I had to start my stream.
And so I was just like, okay, can you be awake now?
Oh no, I want a nap.
I want a nap.
I'm just like, no, no, Doki.
You have to be awake.
You have to stream in two minutes.
But now I'm sleepy.
I'm eepy now.
I was like, no, mom, why didn't you come in the room after
my stream?
Now I'm EP, but now I'm EP because of all the business talk.
Not the EP.
Anyway, so I got some coffee in here at the moment.
Because I need to wake up.
I've been like, there's been like so much work going on.
Like, I don't know.
I think I've like conditioned myself to, so that every time
I like have to, I have like fucking work talk going in.
Like I'm just like, I want to sleep.
It doesn't, it doesn't matter if like I just woke up or
anything.
If I just woke up and I was like, all right, I'm feeling it.
And then they're like, all right, it's time for business
talk.
And then I'll be like, I want to sleep.
I want to sleep now.
I just, I conditioned myself.
No, this is not good.
It's not good that I conditioned myself to be EEPI.
Every time it's like important business talk, important
meeting time.
And then I'm like, important sleep time.
There's only one way to avoid business talk.
Sleeping.
Gotta lift.
I got conditioned EEPI-ness now, guys.
Anyway, um, I'll.
Another news, another news.
There's so many news.
There's so many news coming in.
But yeah, I was like, I was not EP, but now I'm mega EP.
But it's okay.
Streaming always makes me feel less EP the longer I go.
And the more I stream, the longer I stream, the more less EP
I get.
Anyway, anyway, anyway, lots of...
of exciting lots of exciting news coming in uh so um i
didn't realize this until i ended stream last night also
like uh i went to bed really fucking late last night because
like hira and i ended up talking for like i think like three
plus hours straight after we ended stream so i think i went
to bed around like five to six a.m because we just kept
yapping afterwards um uh so she's a great friend um because
like we were just like hanging out and just talking about
random stuff too and uh but anyway i found out after i in
the stream and after i finished yapping with hiro that um it
was announced that i will be at avcon avcon i don't know
avcon in australia Adelaide!
So yes, another World Tour, World Tour spot, Doki's World
Tour spot has been announced.
Another convention that I will be showing up is AVCon at
Adelaide, Australia.
So I will be down under.
And in AvCon for Australian goons, there will be meet and
greets.
So yes, there will be meet and greets well as i think like i
don't know if i can announce it because it's not it's not on
the website itself i should have asked to be like hey what
can i say and what can i not say in terms of like what will
i be doing at av cod because i don't think uh i don't think
they they wrote down yet they've announced what i will be
doing at the the convention i know what i'll be doing at the
So I actually don't know yet.
I should ask first.
But the one thing I can say is the mean and greets.
Because I feel like, you know, even if I shouldn't have, if
I wasn't supposed to spoil it, it's not like it's.
I mean, I did quote retweet it.
So if they're like, oh my God, you shouldn't have said it.
Well, I did quote retweet it.
And they know I quote retweeted.
And they didn't reprimand me for quote retweeting it.
and saying that it's a meet and greet so i think i'll be
fine it's on the website though wait is it okay wait let me
double check get involved okay let's see guest let me see on
the website does it say what i'll be doing no it doesn't say
what i'll be doing it just says like it just says like this
is my bio what do you guys mean the website doesn't even say
what i'll be doing it just says like my biography uh that i
co-wrote you like it i co-wrote that guys you guys almost
baited me in the saying what i will be doing there
you guys you guys almost almost baited me there uh but yes
you guys like this I wrote this okay to be fair to be fair
the organizer wrote it and then I edited it so technically I
wrote this smile
um um at first they included like at first it was like oh my
gosh let me let me not show you guys let me like read off
the original draft because i was i had to edit it because i
was like oh no and they were like it's known for playing
first person shooters drawing sessions musical performances
and just chatting sessions and i was like okay first off
let's let's get rid of the musical performances
makes this real i was like i was like okay i'm gonna get rid
of the musical performance party and then we changed it to
like her tournament performances around the world so i like
i edited a little bit and uh rewrote some stuff uh but yes
if you are going to adelaide to australia you're planning on
to adelaide um i will be at a vcon uh for and maybe you'll
be lucky to get a meeting greet um and for those people on
like different in the different countries around the world
do not worry there's more convention announcements coming
that's gonna be coming out soon the more date weeks that
pass the more announcements are gonna the more weeks that
pass that's getting closer to certain conventions the closer
it gets to certain convention announcements You do not don't
have to worry being like Doki it's so far away from Insert
country here Do not worry there's more conventions That's
gonna come out soon So don't worry Australia is not the last
Look the Doki World Tour is not two conventions guys The
Doki World Tour consists is more than two It's not three as
well guys Like it doesn't stop at three It's not really a
world tour if the tour ends at two Technically it could be a
world tour because it's on either side of the world So like
you know one at an NA and then the other on the other side
of the world So technically it could be a you could say it's
a world tour just because there's It is on like it's on the
upper hemisphere and the lower hemisphere and then and left
and right
The world is only two countries.
Canada and Australia.
We don't know what's in the middle yet, guys.
We haven't discovered what's in the middle of those two
countries.
Another announcement.
Another, another, another little announcement.
The SageM Slime Team.
team i almost forgot two sorry two team has been announced
and apparently i'll be on i was actually really surprised
that i got on the fucking content team i i was i was very
surprised that i got on this team i didn't think i was
actually gonna get on this team but it's gonna be with brawl
pro lazy matman slime and coney so that's gonna be my uh
Tekken 8 team.
The not a king main team.
Exactly.
I can't believe they put me on a team with all these
disgusting king players.
Oh my god.
Like, what am I going to do with this information?
How is he gonna coach me on my actual main playable
character, Eddie?
Yeah.
I can't fucking believe it They want me to fail They Says
that she uploads a dead credo on Twitter Look, I just did it
to see if I could Okay, guys I Um I guess I actually, um, it
was really nice Cause I was asking about like Oh, hey guys,
like Oh, do you guys know And if you have any
recommendations on like actual like like what what what
controller they use uh for for fighting games and uh oh my
gosh what were they it was so nice of them but the junk food
custom arcades actually like reached out they reached out
and dm saying they wanted to send me a um a a free
controller like one of their like mini boxes i think that's
the loverless mini box for free i asked it'll like arrive in
time it'll like i'll arrive in time before they can get some
practice like yeah yeah they will so like they're sending me
uh i love free stuff uh you know why because like that means
money doesn't leave my bank account and i still get the item
okay a snack box micro um is that my gosh who doesn't love
free stuff yeah free free is good um who doesn't love free
stuff so yeah they're sending me a free snack box i think
that's what's called a snack box micro um um and so i'm
looking forward to trying it out uh but yeah i don't feel
like i feel like people are like oh my gosh she did the rdc
but it's not even that difficult to do like why
like no i'm actually not i'm actually serious like i don't
think it was it wasn't that difficult to like get those
buttons like done i just like watched one video and because
everyone was i was like all right uh i was just like okay
what what are the king combos of a character i wasn't gonna
play um yeah it's not difficult and then people were like
wow yeah the issue is can i do it at an actual match though
i'm just a natural grappler what can i say the dokey grab uh
the real talent is if i could do it in a real game um and a
real with a real actual person uh but like i it literally
just took me like five minutes because like they're like
okay you press those buttons and i was like okay i pressed
those buttons i was like oh there it is i'm whoa there it is
it's actually a fun combo though it's i feel like that's
like the first combo like i actually sort of paid attention
to uh do you i do i actually do remember it's right down um
slanted right and then uh what were my controller
you press uh you press right uh down slanted uh uh fuck okay
give me a sec no no no wait wait wait no no no why no it's
it's right down slanted right r3 then right down slanted uh
yx and then b b y bam what is slanted
I almost forgot look slanted is what it is slanted it is it
is technically slanted I am right it's just that I have my
own words look all I'm saying is that before it was called
diagonal it had names okay look look let me tell you guys
the difference between a pioneer and a sheep a sheep will a
sheep will follow what other people would say a pioneer will
invent their own terms
I am not a sheaf.
I am a pioneer.
I fucking invent my own combos.
My own terminology.
So I'm super excited to play with my team.
I can't believe I replaced a super.
I thought that was really funny because my teammates were
all like, oh my god, I can't believe it.
The boys are back and even better because I replaced, I'm
like the fucking replacement for Super.
And they're just like, oh my god, this is the dream team.
You had fun doing a combo.
Congrats, Doki.
You're better than 90% of the FGC.
But then they give us a super chat.
Thank you.
I think the death cradle is so fun because if I hit it, I
don't have to do anything for like 80% of the game.
like it's the best because like because like then i can just
spend majority of time just chilling in the cut scene and i
think that's i think that's why i was really into king
because i realized if i hit these grapples if i hit these
like throws i i get to do like 50 less than the rest of the
player base and
it's it's a good i get down time exactly like in that
fucking if i hit the rdc i'll have i because like what kind
of newbie's gonna learn how to break the rdc anyway like i
don't know how to fuck to break the rdc but anyway it's a
good investment learning all the learning all the grapples
and the throws now so like if i get anybody in the rdc i can
literally leave my controller and just go to the bathroom
and then come back and they're still fucking gripped and
then i and then i put them into another rdc and i leave my
pc get water and then ko like it's so easy it's like
resetting after losing a fight in overwatch who's gonna
learn how to break rdc so he's a girl on team in a team of
only game
that's that's why this is why I this is why I picked king
guys not the plan to be break this is why I wanted to play
king as my secondary character because king is only merely
just a backup a backup for my actual main character which I
will leave as a secret for now he's only he's only the
backup guys and anyway i am super hyped to try out haiti's
tour the early access uh so yeah they just dropped this out
of nowhere and was just like hey guys uh you thought this
was silk song jokes on you guys we actually completed a game
here's haiti silk i'm sorry i'm sorry that's like silk song
does not deserve that random stray hit um anyway uh they
basically dropped Hades 2 out of out of nowhere and um I'm
super excited because I very much enjoyed Hades 1 so I'm
very excited to try out hate that hurts toky I'm very um
very excited to try out Hades 2 just like every other
streamer out there uh because the FOMO was hitting it real
hard the fear of missing out was real hard you guys might i
might be like the 800th and 76th streamer you've watched
playing hades 2 um and uh and now i'm gonna be at 877th
streamer to watch me play watch play hades to yeah area i
heard it was really good i heard that like uh i heard like
majority of the game was practically finished in terms of
like the meat of it and like the only thing they haven't
really added yet was the ending and like some of the visual
assets like some of the like visuals and stuff that hasn't
uh and so yeah there's apparently a lot of content it's not
finished yet it's merely early access but people are telling
me that the ending the ending isn't uh done yet and it's
missing a lot of like just visual assets but like the main
game itself like there's a lot story and stuff a lot of like
audio and stuff is done uh already so yeah it's gonna be
interesting It's gonna be interesting to see.
What's up?
All right, is Sound Guy on?
Sound Guy!
He's on!
I see you, Sound Guy.
All right, let's go.
We're using mouse and keyboard.
Welcome to Hades 2.
This game is in early access, which means we're actively
working on it based on our plans.
Yeah, see?
Early access.
Good luck killing time.
Whoa, whoa!
Whoa, it's so loud.
Yeah.
Meep, thank you for the 20.
Get the shifts.
Thank you, thank you.
How's the new PC, Doki?
Thank you, the super chat.
Thank you.
It's like sitting there.
Like, you know, it's, it's, it's, this PC feels like he's
doing okay.
It's there.
It's existing.
Like, it's, let's see.
maybe turn down the music um let's see oh no sound guy what
do you think sound guy what do you think display v sync am I
full screen or what am I uh 50% brightness interface button
labels disable screen saver uh control attack dash dash Q
special hex what is hex uh what else is there rarity statue
book of shadows forget me not boon info okay i feel like
okay cast i want to move that on mouse and keyboard so yeah
mouse and keyboard oh is hex super move okay hex is super
move so hex f i think f is good oh all right i think for now
god mode you tougher more so whenever you fail failure is
the greatest oh aim assist i love wait actually no we don't
need aim assist guys did i use aim assist last time maybe i
do need aim assist did i use aim assist guys
okay all right that's good all right let's start empty save
slot know i didn't play in advance to make myself look good
as grim lord of the dead came to a sudden end when all at
once his past caught up with him but gods do not go quietly
and history repeats so this tale was only a matter of time
oh yeah what happened to the first hades death to chronos um
who's chronos chronos is like time right uh don't think
Thank you, thank you.
Your Cantonese is excellent.
Thank you.
I really appreciate that.
You're not like my high school friends that make fun of my
Cantonese.
Trauma.
Thank you, Melissa.
Thank you, chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Whoa, Hades.
What happened?
Damn, Hades.
All right.
I have this.
What's this?
What the fuck did I use?
What is this?
Okay.
I have no idea what any of these buttons are.
E.
Kronos is the fathers of Hades?
Oh, shit!
Okay.
Sorry.
It's been a while.
Okay.
There we go.
Sorry.
It's been a while.
Forgot what dodging is like.
I'm already going full king at the moment where it's full
offensive.
No defense.
My favorite.
No knees.
to do defense wait does this like go all the way oh it does
wait nice okay all right i'm learning guys yay poop poop
poop goodbye i have no idea what's going on in this story
but that's okay okay what does this do do i just like snare
them oh i snare them okay all right i'm figuring it out whoa
nice it's fine we're okay And then snare.
Okay, I don't know the range.
I don't... Wait, who's he?
Who's this guy?
It's just another spell.
Accept this message.
Who is this guy?
Oh, Apollo!
You can't get to the Titan, but if you truly mean to stop
him, then the least I can do is light your way down.
Have I seen Apollo before?
I don't remember anything except for Aphrodite and Poseidon.
the snow grandma who I hated the power-ups from.
Nova's strike.
Hi.
Look, the thing is, they're all, they're gods and goddesses.
They're supposed, they're meant to be like the hottest thing
is out there because they're gods and goddesses.
Yeah, they're all supposed to be hot.
Oh, Apollo is new.
Okay.
Let's see.
Your attacks deal more damage.
Your sprint is faster and inflicts daze.
When standing in your cast, gradually restore.
What is the magic required for powerful?
Wait, what should I get, guys?
Blinding Sprint?
Nova Strike?
You guys can't be like, Doki, the game came out.
We don't know what's good yet.
You can't say that.
Because Hades 2 has already been grinded and analyzed and,
like, inspected for fucking hours now.
Like, for, like, days.
Everybody knows what's meta.
It's already been inspected.
and analyze and theorize.
All right, let's do the audio.
Let's see.
You put music at 80, sound effects at 90.
Okay, I'll put the music at 70 then.
And then we bring up the overall game.
All right.
Okay, maybe I'll turn this down too.
But that's ambience.
Whoops.
All right, let's just put...
Alright, and then we'll adjust the game volume.
Yeah!
Alright, here we go.
No roller?
We don't need roller.
We gotta practice M and K for the tournament too.
Because I'm using lever at least.
Boop!
There you go, snared.
I don't like this weapon at all.
Not gonna lie.
I missed the...
I missed the gun and the bow.
I think gun and bow was the best.
Not huge fan.
Hoop.
Oh shit.
What are these guys?
What is the story?
Am I not gonna find out the story until I die?
Just like in Hades 1?
I think that was how it happened in Hades 1.
I didn't find out the story until I died.
Wait.
Wait, what's that?
What did I get?
Mostly used with incantation involving dispelling and
nullification.
Okay.
What the fuck is that?
What are these items?
i'll need these soon enough what what did i mostly used for
unlocking arcana cards common reward for clearing encounters
okay that's interesting i have no idea what they are let me
see what's this what's more important
what's what's more important uh okay you can't say one
because i haven't even given them any numbers yet that one
like do we go with left or right not either wait what are
ashes again is that an ash oh okay ashes are important
Alright.
Spindles.
Why are Spindles?
Oh, that's what's...
Oh, because they spin!
Oh my god, it's like they named these monsters after
kindergarteners!
Okay.
This is it.
I love it.
Like, I don't know if you guys ever seen, like, there was
like a YouTube series where it was like they let...
Like, they try to let kids...
Oh shit!
No!
Excuse me, Spindles.
I am trying to have a nice yapping session with my dragoons.
Like, they're like, let a child...
child come up with like a tv show idea and it is the most
nonsensical thing ever all right simplicity at his best oh
wait that's a is that bone i don't remember oh my gosh i
just i actually don't remember it it's crazy i played this
game for so long but i actually don't remember majority of
this the visuals oh that's right Do I have an alt yet?
Oh!
No!
Ah!
Guys!
Guys, I got distracted!
Guys, it doesn't count!
I got distracted!
No!
Back already.
How does it count?
I looked at chat!
Guys, I looked at chat!
Oh my god, I can put the frogs.
It was ping.
I swear it was the ping, guys.
I swear.
It was the ping.
Oh, is that...
That's me.
Am I the baby?
This old unfinished painting.
Don't look away.
Don't forget all that the titan took.
It doesn't count.
Don't make me restart my game right now and start a new save
file.
You know what?
All right, hey, guys.
Hey, everybody.
So, like...
I don't know if you heard about Hades 2, but...
Oh my god!
I can't wait to start Hades 2 with all of you!
I'm so excited!
Oh my gosh, I can't believe they dropped this early axis.
They dropped this early axis out of nowhere!
I'm so... This is my first time experience.
Whoa, where am I?
No?
Wait, I know Kronos.
Kronos is like the time god, right?
Restore.
Okay, actually that was new.
Just so natural.
Oh my god.
Lost souls.
Okay, and then what do I...
Wait, do I...
Can I not do that?
Oh, wait, I mean like, oh, I don't like that.
key binding give me a sec guys what wow what the heck is
that key binding let me like fix that real quick let me fix
that key binding real fast my first time using this new key
bind okay i'm a youtube gamer what do you mean i'm just
giving my first time reaction to haiti's two in the this is
the first first five minutes playing it we just had a 40
minutes acid on chat wait who is he what's this whose God is
this first
impression wait Apollo has he has he been in the in the
Hades one guys
Whoa, hey guys, which was...
Whoa, what is that?
Who would you be hot, guys?
They're all gods and goddesses.
Of course they're hot.
They're all supposed to be hot because they're a god.
I need my aid.
Let's see if I need this.
Um, I swear I saw it before.
Yeah, from like the stream you watch before me.
Because everybody's been playing Hades 2 now.
So of course you've seen him before.
Like, I don't know what you mean.
Okay, let's lock him up here.
Alright, nice.
Okay, we put, wait.
Alright, we adjust the volume a little bit too.
We put sound effects down another 10.
Okay, I'll put like 62.
And then music down another 5.
Okay, that means 60.
That means 10.
And then And then we'll bring up the game a little bit more.
All right, let me know.
Okay.
There we go.
That should be good, right?
Oh, shit.
No mistakes.
Oh, my God.
No hit run right here.
First time playing, I already got no hit run.
That's actually crazy.
I'm actually naturally talented at this game.
Wait, what's an ash?
Alright, let's grab this real fast.
So close to greatness.
Alright, sound guy.
Let me know if this sounds better.
This game is pretty easy for now.
I don't know.
I don't really feeling this weapon, though.
So far.
Oh, still no hit run.
Still a no hit run.
I don't know what your dad's talking about.
There we go.
Nice.
Oh, oh, wait.
No, oh, shit.
How could he touch me like that?
Does not know I'm a god?
I just hit him from here.
I don't think they can hurt me.
Thanks for rewinding this stream.
Mike, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Why do you need rewind?
Oh, shit.
It's rewind time.
Wait, what's this?
I actually don't know this.
What's the left side?
No, it run dead it's all shit is rewind time left okay i
have no idea what the i actually have no idea what this is
is this a fire is the fire god spindles oh my god spindles
my first time seeing them whatever they are wait can i just
spam this wait i can wait i don't even have to get close to
them i just be like pew pew pew pew pew pew pew pew pew pew
pew pew pew pew pew pew pew Wait!
This is so broken!
The attacks are so slow, so I can literally just spam this.
Okay, and then he gets close to me here.
Yeah, I can literally just spam this in there.
Okay, give me a sec.
Do not expect him to actually get close to me, though.
That was, like, the one thing that was going to counter me.
Distance.
Yeah, I could literally just spam this forever.
It's so nice.
And then...
Well, she says that she dies.
What do you mean?
I made it so far for my first try.
Damn, Doki, doing so good.
Not like the streamer I was just watching.
Thank you.
Thank you for the super chat.
I wonder who that streamer could be.
Was it Boki Derd?
Yeah, Boki Derd's pretty fucking bad at video games.
What a good girl you are.
And here I was just about to burn this old blasted place to
the ground myself.
Oh, Hestia.
Wait, is this another gilf?
Oh my god.
And she's Scottish, too.
See?
There's a granny for everybody.
It's like, would you want a Scottish granny?
Or the other one?
She's new.
Yeah, she's new.
all right your your cast repeatedly inflict scorch or
restore but you have minus 20 20 no what the your special
launches a fiery projectile but uses 10 magic controlled or
i feel like scorch would be better right one wouldn't one be
better yeah but then i lose 20 of health a change to your
bad?
Because I lose my health limit and stuff.
I feel like I'm gonna go with one.
Fire damage.
Wait, another scorch.
But then there's a boss.
But then I can have money.
Wait, is this a shop?
This is a shop, right?
How much money do I have?
77.
Alright, left or right?
Money or granny?
Oh, I lose a shop?
Okay.
Doki Bird is so much better than that last chokin.
Yeah, that sounds like a gamer that fucking sucks.
Sharon.
Oh, hey, there he is.
I'm in your debt, Lord Karan.
These provisions surely shall make all the difference in my
task.
Wait, I don't have money.
Wait, can we actually date him now?
If you date deaf, you can never die.
Pro tip.
I'll just grab the plus one smoldering.
Because you guys fucked me over.
Oh, it's a placeholder.
He just wasn't hot enough.
Sorry, guys.
They were like, whoa!
Okay, don't be that close to the ring guy.
I figured it out.
I learned.
I need to make sure.
Are you fucking kidding me?
I got stuck here because I couldn't dash.
Oh!
Okay, that was bullshit.
I actually got hit by everything that was possible.
That was actually crazy.
Like, anything that could hit me, hit me there.
Oh, my God.
Just don't get close.
Just stay back here.
Safe in your safe space.
There's no way they could catch me now.
I'm safe.
Look at that.
There's no way.
Range them.
This is it.
This is the key.
If I range them, they can never hit me.
Wait, they're arranging me.
Wait, that's illegal.
Wait a minute.
Why are you running away from me?
This was my strat.
They're using my strat against me.
What the fuck is wrong with these freaks?
I'm the main character.
Okay.
That's fine.
If I spam this, if I spam right click, they'll never get me.
Nice.
They're better at your strad.
I don't know what the fuck you're talking about.
Wait, what's this?
What's the time?
There's a time and then there's heart.
I don't remember any of these.
Is that HP?
The god of cheese.
Right side, left or right.
Oh, is this coins?
Oh, they're coins.
They're time coins.
We'll get health.
they're like time coins i see oh no guys guys this is a bit
bad just just a little bit just a little bad all right just
a little bit i just gotta keep running okay nice and then
they'll just go in the fire and then i'll just be over here
You can't get me if I, like...
Oh, see, they can't get me.
Oh my god, I almost, like, fucking ran into that guy.
Because I assumed he was stunned.
Nice.
Easy.
I got my heart back.
See?
Nothing to worry about for my very first run.
You guys said Ash is the best, right?
Ash is better than whatever the fuck this is.
What is that?
Psych?
To activate more.
More mostly used.
Is ash the best one?
To farm?
That's our god of cheese.
Alright, we'll do more ash.
I love cheesing the game.
As well as built for.
This is why I'm totally not playing king.
Alright, I need to stay back here.
It'll be fine.
okay i hate the worms though the worms are actually really
cringe like i can't believe they would like run away from me
kind of player are you okay i can stun these guys before
they do anything which is good and i'll just burn these guys
real fast and then oh i don't like that whoa stay away from
me stay away before me screamer and then get rid of him and
it will get rid of you.
Easy.
They can't use my strut against me.
I copyrighted and trademarked it.
They gotta pay me first.
Wait, what's the purple?
Every time you use my strut, you gotta pay me a 5%
commission fee.
What's the purple?
New.
But is it a good new or a bad new?
Another currency?
What?
Bones are a currency?
Alright, who wants me to... who wants to give me their
bones?
Oh!
What?
Whoa!
They locked me in.
I thought I could run around here.
That's bullshit.
Oh god, oh, oh wait, I don't like this guy.
Wait, wait, this guy fucking sucks.
All right, nice.
Yeah, they actually rushed me.
Actually, really don't.
Oh wait, he's stuck.
He's actually stuck.
Wait, use the trees against them.
Okay, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop, boop.
Nice.
Oh, the terrain kill kills everybody.
Okay, I'm learning.
Bones.
What is the bones?
Common reward for clearing.
Most used for trades for most valuable resources.
I guess I won't find out until I die.
It's gonna be hard because I don't die.
Alright, let's see.
The tree is actually so good for destroying stuff.
Your cast snares them, by the way.
Yeah, I noticed that.
Yeah, the banishing is fucking sick.
suck.
I hate it.
Alright.
Does it sound better now, Songye?
Okay.
Okay, and then I'll just use this and spam.
Wait, never mind.
I should like this weapon.
This weapon's pretty cool.
I'd never have to get close to them again.
Whoa!
Oh!
I stopped looking at my screen!
Okay, so I actually stopped looking at my screen because I
kept spamming.
It's a very nice cheese weapon.
Oh, shit.
Oh, no.
Oh, thank God I snared them, though.
Guys, I don't think they like it.
It's okay, I can do it again.
Yeah, just line up for me, guys.
line up for me
oh it's the other snow granny oh it's because it's ice and
fire she found the cheese
wait is your mom dead oh my god so it's like do you want a
british granny or a scottish granny flavors that's your
grand oh my god okay grandmother your special deals more
damage uh and the flood freeze your sprint forms cycle wait
i can sprint oh hold to run at top speed your attack deals
more damage but uses wait weed killer feels more damage.
Can I do freeze and fire?
Wait, is it possible to do freeze and fire at the same time?
Oh, but then that's a rare.
Wait, you're right.
Is weed killed here?
Good?
Uh, we'll try it, I guess.
Two is the best sprint.
Oh!
They're all good!
She's just to have the worst fucking power-ups, Granny.
What happened?
What happened to me there?
Huh?
One.
Okay.
Ice and fire.
Three is an early winner.
Why did you not say that?
Why did you not say three is an early win?
Early game.
I would have picked that.
No!
Okay, I gain max magic.
Okay.
You can never charge attacks, though.
Oh, shit.
Wait, what?
What the fuck was that?
Wait, I could do that?
Oh, my God.
Guys!
Did you guys know you can charge?
Oh, guys.
Did you know you can charge attacks?
Guys, I discovered a new tech.
Everybody.
Live, right here on stream, the first person to use this new
tech.
No way.
Turkey, please.
Hekate.
Oh, she's my teacher.
Look at her abs.
For all your guidance and the compliment.
In my place, you'd have done the same.
However, now is not the time for pleasant...
I'm pretty sure some of my goons here wanted to get stepped
on by her.
My capability?
My capabilities?
Even though my task has already begun.
Your training shall never be complete.
And I would...
Oh, whoops, sorry, I feel actually finished talking.
What's going on?
Whoa!
What?
Why?
What the fuck?
I don't like this.
Oh, I don't like this.
this oh what the fuck she's so difficult oh oh i'm so scared
i'm actually so scared okay oh she's so down okay okay okay
there's too many things going on my screen there's too many
things going on in my screen i don't like this i don't like
it when i don't know what's going on oh god oh god That
freezer?
I can't tell.
Ah!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
I can't tell!
Oh, shit!
No!
Why didn't I take the epic?
Expert, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
Holy shit.
I don't know.
I think I made it pretty far for my first try.
I mean, I got to the boss stage.
That was pretty good.
Yeah, that was good for a first run.
Hello, little frog.
All right.
How's the sound, by the way?
I remember I asked that earlier for a sound guide, but I
forgot to ask you.
I forgot to read the chat.
This old unfinished painting.
Don't look away.
Don't forget all that the Titan took from you.
they took my family wait so i'm like the sister of hades
that's why i'm hades too because like his parents was like
we can make a better child and then she's hades too wait
what oh they just disturb my eternal rest you trifle with
powers far beyond your comprehension which speak that was
pretty decent right well that may be pushing it okay if i
call you wishless she oh she's gonna be that dora's gonna be
the new uh medusa head that everybody wants to which works
for me in context and i saw the haunting more than all dora
okay here you go i miss medusa you guys have dora now
stand tall and show oh the crossroads come here hello time
forced our hand melanoi merius soul expected you to slay our
enemy last night on a new moon no less but i lack such
forgiveness for my failure had mistress hegati the titan yet
lives and olympus yet burns while i'm back where i started
what is it i accomplished oh god sorry i meant like zagras i
forgot the main character's name because his name was so
like difficult to remember and not easy to the tongue so
like i kept thinking of hades as the main as the little kid
the little punk but i i still believe that hades and his and
his wife was like we're gonna have another child who's
better than you and that's why it's called hades too you're
here to speak of it recovered in body if not
close friends that's why we i call him zaggy
death to chronos is he the one that killed his fat her
family death to chronos death to chronos sounds like a
fucking cult it's being purified what is this it's being
purified who are you tell me you killed the bastard oh
odyssey from that it works on mortals though i have nothing
to report odysseus not yet well you'll get him next time i
reckon oh my god times is he gonna be the new new uh reaper
guy that everybody wants to being as well already hit a wall
knocked your scrawny ass all the way oh my god she's gonna
be the new ex-girlfriend it's insane that she's sending you
out on foot all
skepticism.
Mom.
There's a new ex-girlfriend that everybody wants to be in,
too.
Wait, salute.
Pale shades.
A fight is just getting started.
Holy mom.
Oh, you already ditch Hecatee?
That's so fast.
You're not loyal.
Jackoos, you're not loyal.
You're already willing to ditch Hecatee.
You're witch abs.
What are you doing, mom number one?
What are But not- Hacketeam was mom number one!
Oh hey, she's still alive.
Hypnose.
No ditch?
No, Addy.
They want the whole- You're right.
This- Oh wait, tree!
Headmistress must have some important tasks for you.
Wait, what?
Why- why is dog a statue?
Let me pet!
Guys, to be fair, it makes sense that you're adding, because
this is like...
You know, the mythos back then, the Romans and the Greeks
banged everything.
So, like, it makes sense.
There were orgies everywhere.
We're just following the lore.
Had Mistress lent me the Arcana?
Camp Pet Shit game, exactly.
fair while you channel your moves everything moves slower oh
wait i like that oh that's what the ash is for i see your
foes after you exit location restore heart or choice that
you have no more than 30 deal you know i want to deal 30 me
would actually agree uh hold to run at top speed Wait, I
want to gain 20%.
Is regen actually good?
Wait, how much do I have?
I don't even know how much I have.
But listen, you're attacking special dealer.
Take the heal.
Restore every... Oh, restore magic every one second.
No!
Am I broke now?
Do I have six?
Guys, I think I'm broke now.
That'll do.
I mean, I unlocked a lot of stuff that's nice wait can i
punch this do they have they unlocked more than one weapon
yet like in the early access or like is it only like one
weapon so far oh wait no there is other weapons where are
you that's me oh is that the guy beat up it is now he's like
in war army okay we can't unlock anything yet Can we?
The arms of knight are now at my disposal.
We have the witch's staff.
Silver.
How do I get silver?
It's him, the skeleton.
I want to be greeted on those abs.
Like, jeez, dead foot.
Thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Which is the best one so far for you guys.
What do you guys think is the best one?
A battle lost.
But he has a beard?
One and you have many battles yet to come.
The only question is, are you prepared?
to win.
I'm not so sure here, so let's see you give me 20.
Okay.
Wait, what?
Okay, and then...
And then press or hold.
Oh my god.
I'm running.
Oh, when you hold, you can sprint!
Oh!
Wait, is there a cooldown to sprinting?
Let me check.
Wait, there's no cooldown when it comes to sprinting.
Hold.
And then...
Special, then hold to release.
Alright.
I did it.
Oh, I didn't have to just strike him.
And then...
Guys, I can't believe it.
I could have...
I could have fucking charged this up.
Yay!
Wait, what if I kill him?
Alright.
Goodbye.
that just means i'm better wait is he dead forever no he's
still alive see he's unkillable that means i didn't commit
war crimes wait what's this do i just leave to chronos i'll
see to that no one is more prepared beyond the mists of
arabus there should be a way down too risky heading through
elizium and too risky to stay It's time.
Wait, did I just accidentally started the game?
Oh, no.
It was just lore.
Okay, I'll see it be like, oh, that's awkward.
Oh, that's cool.
I was supposed to run a lot.
I feel like I'm going to get lost.
Not lost, but like, I feel like I'm going to get more
confused if I just keep running.
That sounds like something what I would do.
I just accidentally like run into into the enemy okay is
that everything is there anything else and that's everything
right yeah all right that's time it's time to go out wait
but there's two doors go up or go out go up oh never mind go
down oh now i'm starting okay
him in the name of hades olympus i accept this message
my long lost niece you live hello passadin
how about we turn the tide and extract terrible revenge for
poor old hades and his kin all right your attack hits foe
with a splash that knocks other foes away your cast and
damage and knocking foes away after you strike foes with
your weapon a spirit bubble may appear what the fuck is a
spirit bubble when you touch it expires when you use there's
a there's a ill for everybody oh my god isn't that great I
guess like cast immunity explodes seems really nice right
Okay.
Boom.
Oh, there you go.
Alright.
I need to, like, remember not to, like, I need to remember
not to, like, accidentally use up all my MP in the
beginning.
Okay, nice.
Clear.
Here I go.
One is great.
Well, then.
That's great information to know.
I wish I figured that out sooner.
All right, I'll just charge this.
Wait, spamming is just better for now.
Boop.
It's fucking right, you can't touch me.
Yay!
Nice.
Easy.
Okay, and then spam.
Oh, whoa!
You touched me!
Oh, shit, okay.
I'm sorry.
After I get touched, when I get hit once, I start panicking.
King yeah all right guys wait give me a sec let me mute real
quick I gotta check a voicemail I
never mind like I was getting like spam caught like three
times in a row and then I was like okay there's a voicemail
and then I looked up the voicemail and it was like a two
second voicemail I was like okay I guess I'll I guess I'll
never know.
I was like, all right, I guess I'll never know.
I was like, all right.
Whatever.
Sorry, misclick three times in a row, guys.
Sorry about that.
Do I need to cast this?
Is the casting, like, strong enough?
Like, is it, like, to be worth it?
I don't know.
I can't tell yet.
I want my two seconds of stream back.
I was certain you were gone.
Scarce born, only to be taken by Kronos.
Along with my daughter and those nearest her.
But the witch of the crossroads got you out of there.
Yeah, she did.
word because i'm a secret i'm a secret child all right your
special deals more damage and inflict freeze god i was
hoping i would get like the the rarity the rare uh special
again i take interlocation prime a barrier that absorbs one
wow a whole one damage great wait is this good too i get to
have like my uh i get to reach in my magic Oh my god.
Oh my god.
Wait, that's so fucking fast.
Holy shit Do I need bones?
Do I need bones or do I need ash more?
I feel like I haven't used any bones yet Oh one hit.
Oh One instance.
Sorry English is my first language
Okay, nice and then we hit just do this for now.
Yay!
Oh, shit.
Okay, that's not what I expected.
That's also not what I expected, so we'll snare them here.
And then boop.
Exactly.
There.
Easiest fucking game of my life.
Ash time.
Taking the flowers.
Oh, wait.
That increased my weapon.
Okay.
okay nice oh wait does that slow it down too oh shit okay
nice all right we're okay it's fine it's just like three
damage we'll be fine then we'll lock him in here so he can't
get he can't touch me all right guys we don't need wait i
really like the slow because like now i don't have to i can
be even more lazy with my reaction time that's like my
favorite part yay all right weapon upgrade wait vampire i
can never die but no longer strikes behind you wait i can
strike behind me wait vampire i can never die then oh my god
everything goes for doki always wait who's this hammer time
very so soft divine it was an accident i'm so sorry it was
glowing from lonely dark of night hello there's a spotty oh
you're the new medusa that people want to bang it's tramping
all over my webs that is oh it's nothing silly i can always
make more perfectly good silk i can't always see you It is
our first time we met.
Please no.
Look, if people wanted to bang a snakehead, people were
banging a fucking spider.
You can't judge.
Why then I'll get out of your hair.
You have to go.
But first, you have to try on one of these.
And don't worry about any wear and tear.
I have plenty more to start.
What am I trying on?
What is it?
50 plus outfit that makes you restore 2.
Dawn a 40 that makes you restore.
Dawn that makes you channel.
Wait, isn't channel better?
Should I get channel?
It's 40% faster.
Or temporary health?
No.
Is mana actually better?
2?
Oh, okay.
Okay.
The mana one is actually really good.
I'll do two then.
I'll get more mana.
Oh my, this is beautiful.
Thank you.
Oh no.
No!
It's okay.
I have a vampire.
Did not grab my HP back?
No!
I lost a bit of my fucking armor.
Alright, let's see.
Well, we need max HP.
Oh, I'm so sad.
I'm so sad.
To your success.
Okay.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, wait, I got my HP back.
I did it.
I got it back.
Okay, nice.
We're doing it.
We're actually getting better.
And then...
I can't believe it.
Don't keep actually improving in video.
games oh my god the world truly is ending okay nice what
even is my special wait do i not have a special yet i don't
think i have a special all right 75 uh apparently i need
more ash all right don't keep properly using game mechanics
what a gamer i really do like the slow though The snow is
actually so helpful.
Oh, wait, that hits?
Oh, shit.
No wonder I could...
I'm just saying I'm just naturally talented.
I can't believe it.
Every attack just magically hit.
That's crazy.
all right i'm just gonna be here guys just be here and then
slowly just hitting things up here there we go nice oh shit
okay i did not expect him to fucking show up next to me it's
fine though everything's fine you you just sending an orb of
death over yay is that it just slowly sending an of death.
Just don't touch me.
Yay!
It's okay.
I can recharge.
Yay!
Nice.
Use this game of my fucking life.
What's this?
Wait, what?
I don't know.
I actually don't know what that was.
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Nope.
Oh.
Okay, I thought that would get closer.
Not gonna lie.
Okay, and then we'll kill him with this.
It's okay.
It's slowed.
Now kill him with this.
And then this.
And then that should be the last guy.
Yay!
That was not the last guy.
Not yay.
Fine.
I have mana regen.
Alright.
Oh god.
Almost got hit by that.
Okay.
Hoop.
Whoa!
Fucking fight me like a fucking four-legged beta.
All right.
That should hit them.
Oh!
No!
My honor!
Oh, I'm ready for HP.
That's fine.
That's okay.
I already got my HP back.
He's up to something, but not even Athena knows what.
His assaults on Olympus always fail.
Even if they've kept us occupied.
What's his next move?
What is his next move?
okay your attack deals more damage in larger area your
sprint is faster and flick days on nearby foes okay this
would be helpful if i actually used my sprint how you take
damage your foe takes damage and you flick days on wait
wouldn't lights might be good too one your attack deals more
damage okay we'll do one i see more ones in chat oh ash time
okay i can get to the witch again you know what I'll bet you
I'm going to beat the witch right here.
Whoa.
Okay, I'm going to put this out.
So, I'm going to put this out.
If I keep using this, I'll never get close to me to hit me.
See?
Oh my god, I'm so fucking smart.
And now I'll just regen.
And I'll just do this again.
Count right now.
Oh, wait.
What do you mean you can't?
You can or you won't.
Alright, nice.
Alright.
Can't touch me.
Yay.
I don't need to use charge normal if I can just kill them.
See, I recharge.
Why would I need to use charge when I can just use charge
normal when I can just do this all the time?
Yay!
Okay.
Guys, I think I cannot just do this all the time.
Oh!
I'm sorry!
Guys, I think I figured out that this game will not Let me
use charge all the time.
I can't believe it getting punished.
Say it ain't so.
Uh, what was this?
It's upgrade, right?
Should I get health or upgrades, chat?
Spam magic feed.
Like, what would be better?
Upgrade?
Alright, upgrade.
Uh.
Yay!
Oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, oh, not yay, not yay.
Okay, yay.
It was, in fact, not yay.
I mean, I can just stay up here.
Whoa.
Okay, so then she won't touch me here.
See, I can cast.
Normally.
I don't abuse my power-ups.
No verse strike, geyser ring, Denny's doing that.
Wait, that's so good.
Okay, but that's 25, 35.
Wait, should I get Geyser Ring?
I feel like Geyser Ring or Attack.
Yeah, I feel like I'm using Geyser Ring so much.
Yeah.
Uh, Shop, do I have money?
I have 182.
I still don't know what that is, though.
Alright.
Shop or whatever the fuck that is.
I still have no idea.
Shop?
All right, shop time.
I have enough for actual stuff now.
Hello!
Ooh, Poseidon.
I
mean, he was already a sort of a smuggler in the first
place.
Uh, your special hits foes with Splash that knocks other
foes away after you enter location.
to reduce any damage you would take whenever you claim a
minor fine or similar research a copy may appear i feel like
all these are terrible maybe one i think that two and three
seems fucking terrible god you're so hot when you're just a
placeholder kept my secret from the others all this time
good talk sharon all right heck of tea time heck of tea time
greetings witch i'm back a chill swept through the air as
you approach and seasonably cold now perhaps it is as
demeter desires she aids you does she not she does i mean
all the gods goddesses are helping me have you had
opportunity to speak with her about me and all that's
transpired now I've been a bit preoccupied at least here
Demeter she'll be able to cool her wrath against me for
keeping you a secret for so long all right oh whoa whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa it's okay there's nothing have oh i
missed there's nothing she can do to me for real because i
didn't miss this time nice magic magic time oh magic okay
magic time oh okay that's okay i have armor nice and then
magic and i'll just keep spamming that and then now i oh
it's her because she's talking King!
Oh, shit.
Not my armor.
Oh, this is not good.
I lost my armor because I was fucking around too much.
Nice.
And then slow.
And I'll just keep spamming that here.
Okay.
Nice.
Wait, she has armor.
That's not fair.
Where's my armor?
I'm a witch too, aren't I?
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay, and then, oh, this is Toho.
I don't like this.
I hate Toho.
I hate- oh, oh, oh, okay.
I'm not good at Toho, please.
Why is the first boss Toho?
It's not fair!
Oh, I ran out of mana.
Oh god.
Oh!
Okay, we're fine.
I have the reaction time.
It's fine.
We're halfway there.
Okay, nice.
It's just gonna draw back.
And then, go!
Alright.
It's okay, it's okay.
We're making good progress.
The moment she talks, I know it's the wrong!
Fuck, this is so wrong!
This is the real one!
I got the real Hecatee!
Let's see where they...
Whoa!
Evaded.
I don't know, girl.
I evaded it!
Okay, I can just do this.
I can just spam this.
There you go.
gonna do a hit back i can literally just spam this
oh whoa whoa whoa whoa whoa that's right can't touch me now
oh wait wait wait what's that no okay i'm a sheep now all
right that was a little fucking bullshit not gonna lie i
can't even run as a sheep hello no no that's not fair Okay,
we're okay Wait, if I lose my armor, I don't get my recharge
of mana.
Why did nobody tell me instead of making me read?
People could have told me this If I knew I wouldn't have
fucked around
You guys knew that!
I wouldn't have fucked around!
With my armor!
Okay, now I know, though.
Now I know.
Oh, shit.
Which one is it, though?
It's her.
Alright.
That's all I'm seeing.
If I knew this earlier, I definitely would have not messed
about Turkey Cathery.
You fought with diligence and with ferocity.
Surely there is more for you to learn beyond this threshold.
I did it.
I look forward to it, headmistress.
What about you?
Can you not join me?
Yeah.
me i dare not stray too far from our abode continue now your
task i shall await your safe return well i did it i told you
guys my second run and already defeated hekati i passed the
test i did it yoki you stand still you can still reach in
yeah but that requires me to stand still
there's a problem there already
Okay.
Nice.
First try.
Does he join my heels?
Oh, nice.
I got my heels back.
Yay!
Why won't you and your abs join me?
What's this?
The rim of Oceanus?
It's like an ocean.
Oh, no.
Hello?
Who are you?
Strife Incarnate.
The game?
The RTS?
Things took a ton, Aris.
You know how it goes.
Now, if you'll excuse me, I have some urgent business.
Was that gun?
They had guns back then?
Always in such a rush.
I'd really hate to slow you down.
Though, let's hang out some time, okay?
Have a great night.
Oh, one last thing.
What did she do to me?
Blessed by strife?
Yeah, what did she do to me?
Uh...
What did she do?
Wait, I didn't even say what she did.
Wait, wait a minute.
Oh my god!
Okay.
I still don't know what she did.
She debuffed me?
How do I check?
Whoa!
Wait, how do I check the debuff?
Oh my god, they're so strong.
This is actually not fair Press B
Guys if you guys did not know B does not pause the game Oh
my fucking god I lost so much HP Because I fucking pressed B
Holy shit Fuck you guys I can't believe it That's my fucking
stream Okay Alright Your phone deals 20% damage Okay Alright
that's fucked up Okay, it wasn't me.
Yeah, totally wasn't you.
I can't believe it.
I can't believe that.
Guys fucking me up like this.
Oh, I'm a streamer.
Of course I was gonna press B.
I literally heard press B.
And I was like, oh, B.
I wonder what B does.
If you tell me to press B, First, I'm gonna press it.
Like, it's just simple.
Simple button pressing.
Streamer sees press B.
She presses.
No one told.
Said it was a...
It's because I looked at it.
It should be a pause.
But it should be.
That's why I don't understand why I could not.
Okay, there you go.
I'll just spatton this.
Yay.
Oh my god, they're so strong.
Oh, this is not good.
Yeah, alright, we're gonna...
We're gonna make sure they don't touch me.
By shooting them here.
Oh, this is good.
My attacks are really strong right now.
I'll put this here so they don't, like, touch me.
They don't get close enough to touch me.
Alright.
Nice.
And then we'll get that out of the way.
Woo!
Alright, we're good.
Good.
Yay, money!
For me!
I love money.
They're so strong, though.
I have enough for a shop.
Personal space deployed.
My five meters.
Wait, what's this?
Oh, that's the shield.
Do I have enough?
Wait, I think I have enough.
I have enough to buy a shield.
There's sprint forms in Cyclone.
We enter a location.
Prime a barrier that absorbs one.
Wait, there it is!
There's the weed killer!
You guys said the weed killer is really good, right?
Yeah.
Sprint or weed killer, guys?
But this one's not epic.
Oh, so the...
Oh!
When do I do one?
Okay.
It's better when it's rare.
Okay, I'll do the sprint then and we'll see what the wait
Would this armor be my mana regen armor?
Is this gonna be my mana regen armor guys?
Or like is it like a different armor?
No No, why didn't she make me better armor?
Oh, we'll just buy power up then just extra health.
All right, we'll just buy power up Nova strike.
All right.
Whoa Wait, that's pretty fucking cool.
How do I get to the other side?
Oh, I dash.
Sorry, I forgot about, like, basic stuff.
Um, I don't want to fight a boss, so I'm going to go to
Poseidon.
I'm doing the bare minimum.
Oh, shit!
Alright, and then, cast!
Whoa!
Get away from me!
No touchy!
Alright, nice.
I want to be max HP, so I'm going to max this out.
Oh, wait, they're stuck!
Wait, what?
I didn't get max HP.
How could that be?
Where's my...
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
No touchy.
No touchy, guys.
Wait, where's my vampire?
Oh, God.
Oh, my God.
Oh, gosh.
Oh, no touch.
No touch.
Oh, my God.
What?
No.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
Okay.
It's fine.
Oh, this is not fine.
This is not fine.
Only on charge attacks and only on kills.
Okay.
That's that is also fine.
So I'm just gonna make it so.
Okay.
I need to make sure I don't get hit by that.
No way he can hit me from back here.
I'll just recharge my mana.
Hello, guys.
Hello, fancy seeing you all here.
And then charge.
And then I'll just be here.
Okay, and then I'll just wait until I charge that up.
And I'll wait until I charge that up.
And I should get my HP.
Wait, it didn't give me the HP.
It's when normal cast doesn't work on specials.
Oh.
Guys, I learned.
I finally read the right one
It only took me a bit But I read the right one The left
click It's left clicks Alright After you enter a location
Prime Where you claim a minor find A similar resource or
code Your splash effects from Poseidon also inflicts slips
on foe Oh they can knock first a way after you enter
location to double up okay we'll go with two our enemies
drowned ash time shellbacks why bad I can just spam this and
then yeah oh it's a shell that's why bad yeah but i can do
this and i can just do this i'm full hp now so i don't care
yeah so easy easiest fucking game of my life yeah you can't
fucking touch me okay wait okay give me a sec i just
realized that uh i have no oh no no no no no you touch me
okay nope this is bad i need mana guys give me a sec please
don't please don't hit me i'm just gonna get some mana real
quick it'll just be a bit all right nice oh all right nice i
got wait what he blocked me it's like going into the shell
actually blocks damage no no i'm fucking around okay i'm not
fucking around anymore no we're fucking around all right
guys i can't fuck around anymore i i took Too much damage.
Alright.
We're gonna stay here.
And just chill.
We're just gonna chill back here.
She changed herself.
And I realize.
I realize it's not fun in games anymore.
They hit me.
Yay!
Oh, Ash.
It's right there.
Couldn't find it earlier.
I feel like I don't need coins.
I build up enough, like, coins from this.
Oh!
Okay, nice.
Alright, we broke this.
So I'm going to do this here.
And then, nope.
And then that should give me my HP back.
Is that it?
Or are they?
Oh, he's lost!
All his friends are dead!
Wait, he still has a friend!
He's not technically lost!
Okay.
I really like the I really like the snare.
It's actually so convenient Yeah, full HP Okay Get away from
me get away from me.
Oh Okay, wait, wait, how does that hit me?
Oh It's the arrows It's always the fucking arrows Okay, I
got hit by the arrows accidentally What the fuck what how
did I lose so much?
much!
What hit me?
Okay, actually what hit me.
Oh, God.
I don't even know what hit me!
Uh...
Your special hits a force with splash that knocks the attack
deals more damage in a larger area.
Uh...
Those three orbs?
There were orbs?
I couldn't even see it!
Oh, it's a debuff!
I forgot Every time I get hit, fucking Ares.
There's a reason why nobody invites you to anything.
No one likes you.
Okay.
After you mean...
Okay, we'll do that.
Oh, hey, double up.
Wait, that is so good.
We can have more damage.
Wait, we got another one.
We're so lucky.
Um...
Again?
Gotcha, paid off.
Yay, gambling!
Uh...
One?
Three?
Uh...
Oh my gosh, I don't know, they all look so good.
Two?
Nova strikes for me, two.
Okay, we'll go with two.
Alright, we'll go with two.
Okay, we're gonna...
Ash time!
Ash!
Wow.
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay, maybe...
No, fuck!
Okay.
Maybe now?
Nice.
Gives me a little bit of my HP back.
That's... Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
No, no, no!
Oh, God!
Oh, that's not good.
That is not good.
Okay.
No, okay, I need to stand still.
Please.
Guys, I need... No, please!
Let me stand still and recharge!
Okay.
just a little bit.
Just a little bit.
Please just let me recharge just a little bit.
Oh, thank God.
Okay.
Alright.
Okay, recharge.
Let me recharge a little bit.
These guys are actual, like, griefers.
Not gonna lie.
They're actual griefers.
Oh, it's because he's, like, a mini boss.
That makes sense.
Wait, I can farm him.
I can stand still and farm him.
Oh, okay.
Nice.
Alright.
Yes!
Got my HP back.
Okay, this is actually good for me.
These guys can give me so much HP.
And then I can just, like, put the snare out so they can't
touch me here.
Alright, nice.
Alright, and then snare.
Okay, here we go.
And then I'll just snare them here.
Snare!
Wait, I know the stride now!
okay nice look at that strategy I told you I can use my
brain it's only when it matters and a lot of times it
doesn't matter
it's not my fault that like I'm always on power save mode
guys it's just because I'm on power save mode doesn't mean I
don't have a brain there is actually so good hold Okay,
that's not good though Okay, I just need to make sure they
don't get near me Because there's so many of these little
fucking guys Why are they still existing?
Holy shit Okay Alright, I'm just gonna put a snare here So I
can Be at peace Is it because these are still alive?
Oh my god, there's so many birdfish I felt like I just
killed like a million of them and now they're like an
endangered species easy yeah yeah there's like so many oh
gambling uh I think I can do the shop actually I feel like I
need more HP uh shopper hp guys i feel like i might need
more hp because like um uh yeah we don't have a lot of hp we
only had one hp upgrade so far oh my god bonus gambling uh
no gamba no gamba all right we have 162 gold but no gamba
time who are these guys song compels the nightmare bringing
princess ever forward towards the beauty deeper into the
abyss boss to already of course because i'm a gamer guys
it's very not beating the allegations she's a gamer who's
she is a rock band oh boy look at gals a lady ladies never
come to see our shows you must be I'm Hades, too.
Sirens.
I should have known you are the source of all that singing.
Slinked down into the underworld, have you?
It's the perfect pressure down here.
Beats the pressure trying to make art while all our fans are
watching.
Begging.
Skilla, where's your next soul?
Don't you drown your so-called fans to death?
Have you even got any left?
That means they're really good performers that their fans
are willing to die for them Yeah Exactly How dare you
All right Can I cast her?
Okay, guys cast does not work on them.
Cast does not work on them Okay, well, that's good.
Oh my god What?
what guys can i kill her what okay does cast work on her
okay cast works on her all right that's good that's good we
know okay i'll just cast her oh no
wait this is a bit difficult wait this is actually pretty
difficult guys wait wait wait wait wait dead oh my god okay
I'm so confused oh I don't like this level guys I actually I
wait wait a minute wait a minute wait a minute wait a minute
oh no oh no this boss This fucking sucks.
Oh my god, what fucking timing.
No!
Oh!
I heard that.
This is my new hate.
I hate this boss.
it's brooding to have this memory of all you lost it stokes
your want for vengeance even now bro i never hated it you
know what i okay i hate boss fights where it's not one
person they just add two more they add like more bosses in a
one boss fight game and like it it's just to like spike the
difficulty i hate that mechanic so much i think that's a
fucking bullshit shit boss battle because you have to pay
attention to three different bosses that have their own
fucking pattern that is randomized because there's no way
that they're gonna walk the state like they're gonna walk
similar together hey a scourge upon your bloodline for
resumming me which hey everything okay there ma'am hey dora
oh yes dora it's just skill issue it's not a Kill it, you!
It's a hate!
Alright, bye, Dora.
Is he, like, my, like, friend?
Is she, like, those, like, familiars?
Is she, like, a familiar?
Oh, the culture's ready?
Last night I dreamt of this.
Wait, what's this?
Beta Intervention.
Persuade the wretched broker to peer with whom you may trade
resources for those who know receive.
Wait, I want this!
Mostly used for unlock.
Yeah, we want pickaxe.
Dark of chaos.
Light of me, pickaxe.
Heed now my will.
Alex, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you.
Oh, I got pickaxe now.
Okay, and then I guess we can summon him.
I'm ready.
By blood and darkness, let my will be done.
There.
Yeah.
all right welcome to the crossroads what is he gonna sell me
okay let me talk to a placeholder guy be well oh no that's
heck of tea sorry i swear the the the boat guy and her have
like similar costumes maybe it's because they're both
wearing all black holdings finally purified praise the fates
speaking of which are you as yet considering an invocation
to them i have my doubts that they would listen even now if
there's any chance the three fates shall aid us i'll take it
thank you for preparing things for me though i'm well short
of freshly picked reagents still and offer such reagents if
i could but as you venture past this glade look carefully
along your path aren't they related well one's a witch and
the other one's dead i don't know yes headmistress yay why
are you selling Oh, Ash and Syke.
Wait, what's Fate Fabric?
What's Fate Fabric, guys?
I still don't know what the Syke is for.
It hasn't told me what Syke is for.
What is it?
Eda-C?
Or has it?
Eris has been spotted in the depths along your path.
Intelligence you likely could have used before.
She made your journey worse for you.
Apologies, Goddess.
Yeah, fuck her.
Nobody likes her.
Wait, why is she trying to stop me?
Slow me down.
I'm sure she knows too much about our intentions.
What do we do?
Children of Nix are supposed to be on our side.
Yeah, I thought we were supposed to be really good friends
and roommates.
Of what we've planned.
Besides her boredom drives her more than anything.
Run into her a few more times.
She'll soon grow sick of it and go away.
Are you going to keep doing this to me?
So deems the great tactician.
Why can't we just tell her to stop?
Somebody tell her to stop.
It's like, what?
she's a little quirky just slap her be like bad bad Ares oh
so Kronos took over Hades wait so does that mean no one can
die now because there's no no one can die now because
there's no like afterlife we do a little bit of tomfoolery
wait is there anything Did I miss anything here?
Guess I'll talk to Hypnos.
No, okay.
He's just leaping.
He's just eepey.
Death to Kronos.
Yeah, where do we go now?
Yes and no.
They died.
They just don't stay dead.
Oh, wait, that's good.
We should, like, let Kronos still be the house of Hades.
Well, we need regen.
And then...
Your new Akina card requires more graphs than you have
available.
So you cannot be activated.
Oh, that's what grasp is.
Top right corner to increase your grasp or do.
Oh!
Do we not have enough grasp?
Oh, one more grasp.
Okay, let me...
Now they turn into a ghost.
Wait, then that's good.
I get to haunt people.
I'll be like, you fuck with me.
I'm now going to haunt you forever.
your rasp is psych psyche wait but i could save for your
fabric firmly grasp it all right let's see just breathe uh
gain plus two grasp greater grasp lets you activate more
wait how much do i need i need 12 uh i guess i could can i
get rid of something I like the moose lower.
I feel like...
Well, I can't activate anything yet.
I'll just do all these first.
Sprint is for each night with one death defiance after
every...
Wait, I want to save for a death defiance, actually.
Wait, do I already have it?
No, I'm too low.
It's beyond my grasp.
I could turn this off and put this.
I feel like if I turn...
Yeah, I'm going to turn this off and then we can have it.
I already have regen.
Regen seems a lot better.
Oh,
wait, can I...
Do I have another weapon now?
I do!
I don't!
Okay, it's the pick.
Reveal to me the bounties of the earth.
It just serves you well.
Alright, nice.
Do I have it equipped yet?
i do okay i need to find these wait i can upgrade my grasp i
don't have enough i don't have enough psyche for that
strength and wisdom of my predecessors yeah i need 40.
i have 20.
so i need to start farming psyche now yeah but i want to
save up for the faded fabric i don't know what it is but it
sounds cool there she is again at last why it's the same
thing does he give me
The shadowy denizen of the underworld comes with certain
perks, young one.
Take, for instance, how, when you dash, nothing can touch
you.
We are the unseen.
At one with the darkness.
Yeah, the infinity frames.
I made anything, yes.
But only for a moment.
And even then, I can't prevail by dodging all night long.
I'd do it out of time if I was you.
See the little trail when you dash.
Once it snaps back, you're good to go again.
Oh, okay.
That's interesting.
The crossroads training grounds are watched over by fearless
seafarer, Skelemius, famed in death as he was famed in life.
We cannot fail with such a genius on our side.
What's this?
Oh, restore my magic.
Okay.
Not to look at the scenery again for more lore.
I'll get through all that gloom somehow.
Oh, so I have to go through all of this to reach Olympus.
Am I going to Olympus?
I assume it's Olympus, right?
So pretty.
I wonder if this is a placeholder.
Because I feel like they could definitely improve this one.
Because I don't know.
It sort of looks like a sketch.
It does sort of look like a placeholder.
Alright, down I'll go.
Wait, no, you're right.
No, down is up.
Oh, my God.
You two, please.
Okay, the only other thing I know about Hades too is her,
Aphrodite.
Guys, guys, calm.
Guys, guys, calm down.
Guys, let me...
Guys, calm down.
Calm down, everybody.
Calm down, everyone.
Calm down.
Doubtless this one knows hatred, not just love.
It's her.
You look like you can break some hearts even without my aid.
Oh, your brother would be so proud.
Her eyes are up there, chat.
Her eyes are up there.
Your special deal is more damage to nearby foes.
Your cast.
Whoa!
If you each encounter one foe is always weak, you gradually
restore.
Oh, you're weak foes.
Wait, I like that.
Glamour game.
Wait, what do you mean?
What do you mean, Hades II?
Why do you want to learn more from her?
Okay, nice.
I'm just gonna...
Oh my gosh, the regen is actually so clutch.
Not gonna lie.
Looks like a new path out.
forget the silver what does the silver look like though like
near all of the near endless pathways and suffocating arabus
oh i see it it has like moon rocks very scarce are those who
can all rocks come from the moon i don't know if you guys
know that to figure out silver but how much can't collect
whoa collecting moon rocks that's where rocks are born chat
the moon like cries and then like the tears are the rocks
that come out of the moon ducks and then it falls on the
earth today i learned is that interesting fact guys i
learned that like i learned that like in elementary school
for my science teacher every time you see a rock just
remember it came from the moon
astronomy with those I definitely need heals.
I'm, like, 30 HP.
No, what's this?
No, okay, Majora's Mask.
No, no.
Majora's Mask is different.
Majora's Mask, the moon is trying to kill you.
But, like, but, like, in the real world, the moon is just
crying, because it's sad.
It's sad, because it wants to date the earth.
But the earth, like, always was like, I don't know, man.
Like, I just see you as a real, good friend you know like i
don't know i don't think we can make it work it's just gonna
ruin our friendship all right money or heart i feel like
more heart we don't need money sad moon that's why so then
the moon is like the creepy stalker that wouldn't leave the
earth alone because the moon keeps following them every
every rotation and the earth was like bro come on man Moon
chat god wait the hunt is on who the fuck is hunting me I'm
here talking about my my earth slash moon fan fiction
Oh wait Artemis is that Artemis Artemis help me nice Artemis
is she helping me
though yeah she's helping me nice i can continue my earth
slash moon fan fiction and then like so like and then there
was like a mistake that they made one night we're like um
we're like the moon try to make the earth jealous by artemis
by trying to hook up with the sun and they're like wait
let's get some life first it's been too long hello artemis
look at you on your great hunt circumstances but you finally
she's so different know that the family has your back
surprises they are about this no shortage lately of
surprises on olympus or below it's good to see you and your
couple name is eclipse times against us and all that times
an old fool too busy besieging the mountain of the gods to
sense the threat headed his way go get him all right those
will at least may take critical damage.
A random foe occasionally becomes marked.
If it takes critical damage, this repeats.
Fodes in your cast may take critical damage from your
attacks.
Cast?
Wait, wouldn't that, would lethal snare be good?
Because I'm snaring a lot too, I feel like.
Or unless we get death warrant.
Two or three.
If random foe occasionally becomes marked, I feel like snare
would be better.
Just because I'm always snaring.
And then it may take damage.
Yeah, I use snare a lot.
Alright, we're gonna go with snare.
Goodbye, Artemis.
We're gonna need Sykes so we can grab more.
Why can't she do that all the time?
I don't understand.
She should be helping me all the time, because we're
sisters.
Black, thank you for the super chat.
Thank you, thank you.
And then the Earth has to, like...
Wait!
Armor time!
Wait.
Not armor time?
Yeah.
oh i found it wait does that mean wait that was easy does it
mean these are monsters i assume these were monsters right
yeah or i did it first try fistbo thank you for the super
chat thank you thank you the moon orbits the earth but the
earth orbits the sun love triangle thank you
thank you the super chat big thank you the earth and moon
banged once 4.5 billion years ago and learned that they
weren't meant for each other it was like a mistake you know
so and that's the earth knew it was a mistake but he can't
let go but the moon was like no give me one more chance
earth oh shit i just want more money that's fine i just want
more money so we're just gonna do this for money guys like i
already fucking oh guys why did i do this for the money okay
this is actually pretty bad okay i i realize i don't have
vampire no i did not mean to kill this guy too okay oh my
shop shop shop no no it's locked okay okay this is bad this
is bad i forgot i don't have vampire so like This is not as
fun.
Alright.
Nice.
We'll go get Psyche.
Actually, we'll go grab.
We'll go to the shop.
No!
I don't have enough money.
But we'll upgrade, I guess.
No sign of Hermes yet, my lord.
Forgive my impatience.
I know infiltrating our enemy's ranks and discovering the
details of his plans to conquer Olympia.
This is sensitive work.
Hmm.
Of course.
No.
The boatman, Karam, one-time steward of the dead, now skulls
the rivers of the underworld in aid of those who yet resist
the Titan Lord.
Oh, just Kronos the Titan Lord.
What would we do with that?
So we're just trying to help him.
All right, let's grab the Moon Tears again.
Yay!
More Moon Tears!
okay let's snare them here so they can't hurt me and then
we'll use that and then we'll have money and then we're just
gonna get them away from us oh wait that's fine they're dead
anyway yay oh he's a weaker one a weaker child nobody loves
you because you're weak as fuck all right we're just gonna
get rid of the spinners and then the little guys here we'll
stun lock them Nice.
Wait, where are you doing?
Why are you watching me?
Go help.
Fire time.
She's much,
much older than she looks.
Whoa, what?
Appearances are everything to her.
Whilst, as for me, I'm about hotness of a different sort.
Who's older?
Has she or Aphrodite?
Wait, does that mean Aphrodite is all plastic?
Is that what she Is that what Granny Grandfire is trying to
apply Gain but give up one Ha ha ha ha ha And Sia's like no
fucker Give me Give me your glamour Alright your cast
repeatedly Scourge foes Your special inflicts foes Uh Uh
Let's see Do I do Yeah I use cast a lot we'll use cast flame
of the horse oh i stroke grammar i feel like i should keep
getting more psyche because i feel like i have not been
farming psyche and i really need more psyche so i can have
more cards to use all right let's go this is the tenant
we'll do this and bam i need to be more careful because like
uh i definitely don't have vampire anymore So, like...
Oh!
So, so, like, my life...
This is actually life or death now.
Alright, nice.
And then we're just gonna get these guys out of the way.
Alright, snare them.
Alright, nice.
And then...
Easy.
Yay!
I still don't know what...
Oh, no, this is magic.
Okay, so I'd rather just...
Oh, grab this.
Wait, does that...
makes my max magic stronger.
But who cares about that?
It's all about power-ups.
Uh...
Okay, and then I'm gonna line this up for real fast.
And then line this up.
I know!
I feel like the common enemies are easier, but by fucking
God, the bosses are so difficult now.
I feel like level the first level and the second level
bosses were not as hard as this definitely feels like common
enemies are easy bosses are hard they got through do you
mind your time sunshine the titan thinks he has us pinned
but we have the situation here under control yeah the titans
are like they might be pre-gods and goddesses but there's a
reason why the titans are all died out all right wait lucid
wait while standing in your cast grab wait what exchange
heroic but it's heroic while standing your cast gradually
restores what was glamoring in uh do i get this okay i don't
need glamour
Uh...
Wait, I want this because I want the fabric.
Okay.
That's good, right?
That's right, you can't touch me.
Oh, he can touch me.
Alright.
Nice, so I can just stand here and farm.
I can literally stand here and just farm this, right?
Whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa, whoa.
Okay, and then...
Let's see.
I'll cast and then...
Oh!
No, no, no, no, no, no, no!
Alright.
Nope.
Alright, and then cast.
Oh, God.
Okay.
Just keep casting.
Oh, my God.
Wait, this...
Oh, shit!
No!
Okay.
Anyway, I can keep farming this.
Because all I do is just... I do infinite cast.
And then I just farm it inside my cast.
For me.
Yeah, I have the regen.
Oh, I need to grab the...
I need to grab the...
The thingy.
Oh, well, I don't need magic anymore Because, like, I have
infinite cast Yeah And then I'll just do this And then I'll
just do this And then I can cast this And I'll just stand
here And then...
Wait, how do I lose it?
How did I lose my magic If I'm infinitely charging?
And I do this Fucking easy Oh my gosh, the easiest game my
life yeah i can just kill all of them here i don't even need
a sprint hello granny i'm back your attack inflict scorch
your fire launches a fiery projectile but uses my special uh
whenever scorch afflicted float foes are staying slain i
have scorch right i've cast scorch wait this is good natural
gas with my cast
uh weren't it because then i have like my my cast plus yeah
natural gas plus my cast you're not charging special use
yeah exactly fire it up i still don't know how to use my
special do i even have a special i did that's the thing i
don't have enough for the shop though i only have too so
maybe i should go for an upgrade i actually don't have
enough for the shop i have only 100 wait oh this is my
special oh whoops whoops uh i should go through yeah special
is my rank i keep forgetting that special is my range attack
oh my god i can make a better heroic i'm gonna go with
ahead of the underworld princess shall again confront the
one who raised her and taught to her the means by which she
may prevail okay so I'm to kill my my my spiritual mom there
you are it's me you surpassed me before yet I wonder was it
your mastery over our craft or did the fates themselves
perhaps provide a little
This is easy.
I'm heroic now.
I might not have regen, but I have regen and mana.
It was not a fluke.
It was all scared.
All right, here we go.
See?
Oh, whoa, whoa, whoa.
And then I do this.
Okay Okay, that's not fair
That's not fair she doesn't get stuck in my cast Oh God,
okay, and then I'll do this and then okay, that is no,
that's that's a fake.
That's a fake That's also a fake.
That's real.
He's real.
No Guys, I think I...
Guys, regen might have been a crutch.
Just a maybe.
I'm not sure yet.
It's a maybe.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no, no.
We're fine.
I can run.
Okay, and then we're gonna get rid of you.
And we're gonna get rid of you.
And then we're gonna get rid of you.
You're weakest head.
Easy.
And then you're gonna...
be over here, right?
You're gonna...
You're gonna be over here, right?
Oh, oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no,
no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, I'm trying Okay, no,
that's not the real one Of course I chose the non-real ones
Of course Alright, just half HP That's good No, no, no, no,
no Let me cast Okay, and then cast Cast Cast Okay, and then
we go this way easy cast cast I'll just stay here in my cast
circle it's like the it's like that circle in SpongeBob oh
nice there it is it's like the SpongeBob circle the sand
bear can't get me no how do I dodge that it's not fair for
the sea bears sorry it's the sea bears like how do i fucking
dodge that no are you kidding me oh no oh no i'm 37 hp oh oh
gosh get the witch get the last witch all right no no no no
you gotta get rid of all the witches okay and then please be
over here Please be over here.
Nice.
Oh, no, no, no, no, no.
No, I got stuck.
Is this the right one?
Nope, it's not.
This guy.
Okay.
It's fine.
I can just farm this here.
Oh, nope, I cannot.
Yes, I can.
Nope, I cannot!
Oh, my god.
Guys, I made a mistake.
Guys, I might have made just a little miscalculations.
Oh, God.
Oh, okay.
I'll just keep casting right here.
I'll just save my little safe zone.
No, no, no, no, no, no.
My little safe zone right here.
Come on.
Keep casting in your safe zone.
Oh, God, please.
No, fuck.
Right here Come on, no, no, no, no, no, no, no, no!
I threw!
I touched it!
I actually touched it!
Three, two, one!
I'm not greedy!
I was like, I got this!
Where the fuck is this child?
I am a forsaken princess.
I can't believe I dashed into it.
I can't fucking believe it.
It was literally 1 HP.
I can't believe it.
I choked.
The keen-eyed princess finds a set of tracks, suggesting
that her foe...
I can't believe...
I dashed into it and all I got was lore.
Oh my god.
I'm sure if you're going to describe look so fucking hell no
she looks so so like not their child looks so round yeah the
art style is like I guess it's the art style as she
continues on her fateful search the art style looks like
different from like the usual art style
She looks like Steven Universe.
There you are!
I found you!
Got you, Hecati!
You're dead!
Got me, you did, Melina.
But I dare say I can escape your clutches yet!
Whoa!
Wait, she's gone!
Where did you go?
You'll find her yet.
Odysseus!
Odysseus, where did she go?
a little while little goddess though i'd expect that pointy
hat of hers to give her away i'll look for it all right
thank you uh yeah where is she where are you wait if i was a
i'm a goddess oh there she is i see her there you are got
you again i'm the best hide and seek finder there is so
persistent give up already which for i'm a Wait, is she also
a titaness?
Or are they role-playing?
I thought Hekate was a witch.
Where is she?
Where did she go?
Hello?
Hekate?
Hekate, where are you?
Oh, they're larping.
Oh, I see.
Ye old ancient larp.
Where did she go?
Oh, there she is.
I see her.
Hello, Hekate.
I got you Oh, she is a Titan I thought they were all dead
Except for Kronos Like, gods and goddesses killed off all
the Titans I've not heard your laughter before Reminded me
of your mother A much preferable sound To that of grief I
promise not to cry again I still get sad sometimes Oh no Why
are you sad?
Your parents are still alive We think Do not make promises
you cannot keep.
When tears well up, let them...
Why is she abs?
Be a witch's hard work, okay?
She did not skip the gym.
But you never cry, Hecatee.
And I wish to become strong like you.
So that I might find Kronos and destroy him for what he's
done.
And then...
And I shall do everything in my power to prepare you.
So that you may succeed where I fail.
If not, be your family's sake, then be your birthright.
Like a child actor?
That's me!
But I thought my brother's gonna inherit the underworld.
What do you mean you failed?
You tried to beat Kronos yourself.
He hurt you?
Concern yourself with your own pain, not mine.
Destroying Kronos shall not change the past, and the pain
shall linger.
less frequently with age but enough of this on the morrow we
shall teach you to hunt greater prey oh my god we're gonna
start killing let's teach the child how to kill kill kill
death to cronos death to cronos oh wait I just I don't have
an arm you're right I just noticed I'm armless let's pet the
frog yeah I don't know where Neal ready, am I?
Alright guys, I know this is a short, really short stream.
But I'm going to call it here because I'm tired.
We're going to call it here.
We did stream like two and a half hours today.
Yeah, I'm like super tired right now.
So we're going to call it here.
I don't want to force myself when I'm like really tired.
But I honestly had a great time playing Hades 2.
I think like I'm going to play Hades 2.
I'm going to wait until like the game gets out of early
access to keep playing.
Because I don't want to like spoil myself.
I don't want to spoil myself the full experience.
And then like, and then when the game officially comes out,
I get like, I like, you know, I get bored of it.
So I want to like, the next time I play Hades 2.
i'm gonna wait until it's fully released and then we'll
we'll play back to where it started i don't want to get
burned out on it uh yeah i don't want to get burned out of
it and like i actually sort of like want to um i want to
like be able to experience the full story in in the way that
the game wants me to so the next time we're playing hades 2
we're going to wait until the full game is out.
Um, but I really enjoyed it.
Um, I really enjoyed it so far.
I enjoyed the different power-ups and everything, and um, I
cannot wait to play Hades 2 when it's out of early access.
Uh, I hope, I heard it, like, planning on getting it out of
early access by the end of the year, right?
Or next year, I don't...
We'll see.
But yes, I had a great time.
I'm sorry that it was a really short stream, guys.
Uh, but honestly I'm like really tired in general at the
moment I think it's also because like uh there was a lot of
stuff going on behind scenes so uh I'm like mentally my
brain is just so exhausted at the moment I might take a nap
right now after this uh after I end stream but I still hope
you guys had a really fun watching me play Hades too uh um
being the many the 877th streamer you watched today uh in
the past week that played this game anyway everybody as
everyone stay hydrated posture check get up and move around
to get that blood flowing and if you stay up for me head to
bed because you deserve it i'll see you guys next time
everybody bye guys